the besieged city of mariupol in ukraine
has been under constant russian
bombardment since the beginning of the
war
more than half the population has fled
while up to 170 000 others remain
trapped without food water or
electricity dw correspondent rebecca
ritters met one doctor who spent 25 days
and nights helping the injured until she
too took the chance to flee
through almost four weeks of war and the
most unspeakable conditions
anna a neurologist worked and lived in
the mariupol city hospital now in the
relative safety of lev she tells me of
her ordeal
during the heaviest bombardments we had
around 50 patients an hour arriving a
day the hospital was so overcrowded and
the windows doors and roof were all
destroyed
stayed up
not long after it got even worse the
russians cut the water supply
we would gather snow rain water use the
water from inside the boilers and
disinfect it
so many patients were dying she tells me
they were forced to put the corpses
outside in bags
the worst thing was when the relatives
would come to look for their loved ones
they had to open all the bags
the bitter cold they're saving grace as
it prevented the worst of the stench
they should butcher what i saw i think
that even the most perverted minds
wouldn't be able to imagine
[Music]
the night of the 20th of march i named
this night the genocide
i would cover my head like that
and think this one will be the one that
gets us
a moment comes and it's hard to
comprehend
a moment when you want it all to be over
in a good way that you survive
or in a bad way and you die
and you don't care how you die
just as long as it's all over
and soon it would be she and a few of
her colleagues took their chance to
escape
we were driving and then in the distance
we saw our flag our blue and yellow flag
and ukrainian troops
one of them gave me a hug
and it's weird but i asked him
can i be a ukrainian here is it safe
and he said yes you're at home
never a doctor
alive but dead inside she tells me as
she faces a life haunted by what she's
witnessed
when the world sees what happens in
mariupol it will be butcher multiplied
by 10 by 100 by 1 000.
and our correspondent rebecca richards
who filed that report joins me now from
levi
rebecca this war is leaving so many
people traumatized including the doctor
you spoke with are they able to get any
help dealing with the psychological
impact of what they've endured
terry it's hard to comprehend how people
particularly people like anna have
witnessed and experienced some of the
worst of this war are going to be able
to carry on in its aftermath and it's by
no means over so
there are going to be plenty more
stories like this uh alive but dead
inside is how she ex
described her feelings and her state of
mind at the moment now if you
extrapolate that across all the people
who've
seen and witnessed this stuff we're
talking about a nation who are going to
be traumatized from this war there are
organizations here ngos set up to try
and help with the psychological aspects
of the trauma but
obviously they that is
sad to say a secondary factor because
the immediate factor of trying to
re-house these people to have them
registered for government assistance
when they're no longer allowed to earn
able rather to earn money
takes precedence so the psychological
aspect element will come second to that
now anna herself said that she hadn't
yet
received any psychological support we're
actually going to try and help set her
up with an organization
because they're not necessarily it's not
an official process yet there are just
so many other immediate factors but it
is something that is going to be these
organizations are going to be uh working
very hard in the weeks and months ahead
years in fact terry
you're in la viv rebecca in western
ukraine what's the situation there right
now is it still considered relatively
safe
it is a relative is the word there terry
i mean you can probably see behind me
i'm in the main square there are people
walking around i mean in many respects
it feels
like a relatively normal city uh despite
the fact that everybody there's not a
single person in this country who's not
been touched by this conflict
it's been a little over a week since the
last explosions here uh
at that targeted the oil depots
and then until last night when about 70
kilometers to the north west in an area
called radikiv some administrative
officers were targeted uh we it was too
far for us to be able to hear anything
from here but the sirens were worrying
um so just goes to show how close the
conflict can be and though this city is
is relatively safe day today just how
close the conflict still is
rebecca thank you very much our
correspondent rebecca ritter is there in
la vie
you